[Music]
here's the first coffee table book it's
called Mitch McConnell having fun now
that just looks like he's got a whole
sleeve of rich crowd isn't that nice
that whole thing yeah and here he is on
the back looking at grass seed yeah and
then there he is filling up like a Brita
filter that's good very nice I don't
understand why it didn't sell but I got
it for cheap look at this one it's
called passive aggressive barista art
passive aggressive barista that is a
bitter barista right there problem yeah
very good though
now this is I thought a fascinating one
aha this is photo bombed famous photos
photo famous photos were someone's photo
bombing you can see right there that's
just such a historic moment it's such
effort to face look at this [ __ ]
right here just take me hell yeah and
then this is really just wrong shouldn't
be doing that things go wrong yes I'll
give that bad right that just happened
it's just little bad it happened all
right now a couple of weeks ago everyone
was talking about the cat that saved a
boy from an attacking dog yeah that was
a huge story we'll check out this book
they've already made a play already made
a book and it
hey alright they already made a book and
it already didn't sell Wow such a fast
world we live in you
well anyway that cats right right okay
we'll go these are cats that wouldn't
have saved that kid from that dog
[Laughter]
[Applause]
these cats just don't care he's watching
a kid get mauled by a bear hold them not
to play in the front yard
not my problem all right here's a book I
quit I kept me a sitting cell it's
called Amish douches
[Laughter]
oh man yeah ice churn tech yeah churn to
act churn tech I don't have a lot of
time to use full words turn tap turn tap
gets it out yeah check this one out
beloved children's characters played by
Sons of Anarchy actor Ron Perlman
there's there's the Easter Bunny right
there man he's a good Easter Bunny and
look there's Patrick from SpongeBob and
Dorothy from The Wizard of Oz he's a
great actor no matter what role he then
he becomes each character he becomes
them yes he does
yes he does okay this one's called porn
actors in new careers that's right
there's a porn actor in a new career
right there and
[Laughter]
this is nice I look at when I have a
dialogue right exactly they let me know
yes when we've missed the mark you
create a problem and then you solve
exactly with their help we work together
here's a coffee table book it's called
Shai Stallone Oh yo yo Adrian yeah
[Applause]
he's that's a federal law that worked
out fine here's one here's a copy of a
book called poorly planned sandwiches
[Laughter]
you gotta distribute the you know yeah
you gotta like it comes read ratios yeah
better and then finally and Gettys bein
babies
check out bein babies right there that's
as soon
[Laughter]